Trascrizione: Lucia Di Gallo
Revisore: Michele Gianella
10 alla 25 o se volete 10 quadrilioni.
Che cos’è questo numero?
È il numero di pianeti
che ci sono nell’universo.
Chi li ha calcolati?
Li ha calcolati un astrofisico,
Ethan Siegle
come ha fatto a calcolarli?
beh, non li ha contati uno a uno,
ma ha fatto un lavoro statistico.
Ha contato i pianeti che,
fino ad oggi,
i telescopi spaziali sono riusciti
ad individuare
sono circa 4.500
Poi ha fatto una statistica:
se in una zona così vicino alla Terra
ce ne sono così tanti
ce ne saranno un tot
nella nostra Galassia.
Ha moltiplicato per
il numero delle galassie dell’Universo
ed è uscito questo numero.
Non riusciamo a concepirlo vero?
però, sicuramente,
tutti diciamo
è molto probabile che
tra queste innumerevoli stelle e pianeti
C’è sicuramente la vita.
La vita e anche la vita intelligente,
forse più intelligente della nostra,
un'intelligenza diversa.
Come sono intelligenti gli animali
in modo diverso.
Ma la domanda è:
perché noi abbiamo questo desiderio
di conoscere se ci sono degli alieni,
alieni intelligenti.
Perché dentro di noi c’è questo desiderio?
E non ditemi che non è vero
che tutti, una volta nella vostra vita,
vi siete detti:
“non possiamo essere soli”.
Per rispondere a questa domanda un viaggio
indietro nel tempo di 300 mila anni
300 mila anni fa in certe zone
dell’Africa iniziò
a nascere l’Homo sapiens.
Noi,
in diversi posti non in un solo luogo
a differenza di quel che si pensava.
Poi questo uomo è uscito dall’Africa e
è arrivato in Asia in Europa.
E circa 20, forse 30 mila anni fa
ha attraversato lo
stretto di Bering e poi giù nelle Americhe
Perché questo? Beh, perché, a quel tempo,
aveva bisogno di nuove terre.
Il clima cambiava,
è sempre cambiato,
e aveva bisogno di
andare a cercare nuovi territori
dove ci fossero animali,
dove si potesse fare agricoltura ideale
e quindi c’era questo desiderio di andare.
Ma, sicuramente nel loro cuore c’era anche
il desiderio di chiedersi
ma ci sarà qualcun altro oltre a me?
Erano piccole tribù
Ci saranno degli alieni?
Forse, forme diverse,
con i quali possono rapportarmi
e trovarono chi? I Neanderthal,
i desi nova, si unirono.
Erano gli alieni di allora.
Ma vorrei farvi riflettere sul numero
250 mila anni.
Questo è il tempo che l’Homo sapiens ha
impiegato a conoscere il nostro pianeta.
250 mila anni.
Per noi, non riusciamo ad avere un’idea.
È quasi come 4 10 quadrilioni, quasi.
Ecco bene,
questo è il tempo che l’uomo ha impiegato
per conoscere il nostro pianeta.
Chissà fra 250.000 anni dove saremo.
Certo, in questo periodo l’uomo
è dovuto andare a cercare
terre nuove per sopravvivere.
Noi invece oggi,
questo Dna,
che ha fatto sempre esplorare
lo usiamo per cercare nuove intelligenze.
Certo, non possiamo fermarci
a cercare nuove terre.
Perché?
Perché mal che vada
fra tre miliardi di anni
il Sole sarà una stella diversa
e la vita sulla Terra
non potrà più esistere.
E quindi abbiamo l’obbligo
come quei Neanderthal facevano
per i loro figli
noi abbiamo l’obbligo per i nostri
nipoti dei nipoti
di andare a cercare nuove terre.
Non lo facciamo per puro sfizio.
E allora questo desiderio di andare a
cercare gli alieni è già partito.
Lo stiamo facendo,
andiamo su Marte.
Qualcuno ha già individuato,
vedete sulla sinistra,
con forme che ricordano
forme di vita antichissime
che c’erano anche sulla terra.
le stromatoliti, si chiamano così,
il Viking, sonde degli anni 70,
che hanno trovato qualcosa a cui
gli scienziati non riescono ancora
a dare una risposta.
E poi stiamo cercando la vita
sotto i ghiacci
di alcune lune di Giove di Saturno.
Lì ci sono degli oceani
oceani relativamente caldi e salati
e portrebbe esserci vita,
e vita,
non microscopica come su Marte
ma addirittura dei pesci.
Però, se trovassimo la vita qui,
nel nostro sistema solare,
io sarei emozionatissimo,
ovviamente
farei un programma,
sicuramente
ma non sarebbe una scoperta eccezionale.
E come se voi,
se avete un giardino,
mettete la testa nel giardino del vicino
e dite:
“To’, guarda, anche quello
ha piantato i pomodori”
e certo, i pomodori ci sono nello stesso
negozio dove sono andato a comprarli io
e qui siamo nel sistema solare nostro
I semi che hanno dato vita alla vita
si sono fermati forse
anche da altre parti.
Completamente diverso sarebbe
se noi trovassimo un pianeta lontano
dove lì c’è la vita.
Una stella lontanissima,
addirittura di un’altra galassia.
E immaginate se ci potesse arrivare
un segnale radio
che ci dice “siamo qui”.
Allora, cosa sarebbe di stravolgente?
sarebbe il fatto che
noi potremmo dire, chiedere a loro:
Ma voi, pensate anche voi che c’è un Dio?
Ma voi, come siete messi con le guerre?
Ma voi, come siete messi con i virus?
Ma voi: lavorate ancora o
avete risolto il problema dell’energia?
avete risolto tutti i problemi
e la vostra vita è fatta solo di pensiero?
Pensate a quante cose
potremmo chiedere loro
che noi ci facciamo e
non riusciamo a rispondere.
Ecco perché sarebbe stravolgente.
E allora qui,
Allora qui
la religione, la filosofia, le scienze
si mischierebbero
Sarebbe una cosa spettacolare
Sarebbe una cosa meravigliosa
e questo viaggio alla ricerca di alieni
l’abbiamo già iniziato.
Tutti questi sono i telescopi
che stanno cercando per il momento,
ahimè,
Siamo poveretti,
le impronte della vita.
Ma
Se ci sono gli alieni non è che
magari ci hanno già trovato loro?
L’universo ha
13 miliardi 800 milioni di anni
noi siamo qua, noi vita,
da circa 3 miliardi e 800 milioni.
E quindi c’è un lungo tempo
dove loro potrebbero essere nati
e aver scoperto chissà che cosa.
250 mila anni per conoscere un pianeta
ma loro avevano a disposizione
10 miliardi di anni
e magari ci hanno scoperto
E allora perché non vengono qua?
perché non si fanno vedere?
Qualcuno conosce
la filosofia di Star Trek:
non fatevi vedere
se non conoscono la “curvatura”.
Se trovate una civiltà
non andate ad influenzarla
finché quella civiltà
non ha conosciuto la “curvatura”
viaggiare più veloce della luce.
E magari loro davvero la pensano così.
“oh, questi terrestri, guarda
sono lì ancora con
le macchine con i pistoni
stanno pensando alle macchine elettriche.
Lasciamoli.”
Magari sono passati qua vicino,
qualcuno di voi ha sentito parlare
di questo oggetto:
Oumuamua
un asteroide, un oggetto
che è arrivato sicuramente
da un altro sistema solare
è passato vicino al sole
e poi è partito se ne è andato
per il 90% della gente questo Oumuamua
è un asteroide o forse una cometa
ma c’è una comunità piccola di scienziati
che dice che per il modo con il
quale si è comportato
potrebbe essere
davvero un'astronave.
Quindi magari ogni tanto passano qui
ci guardano e poi se ne vanno
e aspettano, attendono
e c’è tanto tanto tanto tempo.
Oppure non vengono qui perché,
chissà
Sono fatti di antimateria,
sì certo antimateria
fino a un po’ di mesi fa addirittura
l’antimateria non poteva esistere
si era annichilita tutta quanta
all’inizio dell’universo
Invece adesso ci sarebbero delle impronte
che dicono che ci potrebbero essere
galassie di antimateria
e allora loro sono fatti di antimateria
e sanno che se venissero a contatto
con noi che siamo fatti di materia
dandoci la mano
diventeremo energia pura.
E allora se ne stanno lontani.
Quante possibilità ci sono poi ancora.
Ma, domanda:
è giusto contattarli?
è giusto che noi cerchiamo
di contattare loro?
cosa potrebbe succedere?
magari sono civiltà che vorrebbero venire
qua da noi per portarci via tutto.
E allora
è giusto che noi ci facciamo sentire?
Ormai però l'abbiamo fatto.
Da alcuni decenni
abbiamo iniziato a inviare
segnali radio, televisivi nello spazio
abbiamo addirittura mandato un segnale
ad un gruppo di stelle
lontano 31 mila anni luce in M31
dicendo
“Siamo qui!”
forse, è come se fossimo nella savana e
abbiamo gridato: “aiuto”
e poi diciamo: “Oh, mamma mia,
non vuoi vedere che dietro c’è il leone”
eh, ormai lo abbiamo fatto
e allora
noi dobbiamo accettare tutto questo.
Ma, cosa succederebbe se
domani mattina arrivasse il segnale?
Eh beh,
chissà quanti ne parlerebbero.
Ma io sono convinto che
ne parlerebbero
per 15 giorni, 20 giorni.
Siamo una società, ancora,
dove non riusciamo a capire
davvero le cose importanti
e quelle no.
Forse qualche ragazzo direbbe: “ehi, ma
io posso farmi un selfie con gli alieni.”
No non puoi farlo
e allora, nel giro di un mese,
un mese e mezzo, due mesi
ricorderemo quel giorno lontano in cui
sono arrivati i segnali degli alieni.
A meno che, a meno che quei segnali
degli alieni nascondono qualcosa
che ci dice che
potrebbero invaderci.
Allora diventeremo veramente,
come in un film di fantascienza,
tutti fratelli,
tutti pronti per combattere tutto questo.
Ma io non voglio crederci
a tutto questo.
Solo una cosa,
una cosa importante
là fuori, forse
ci sono queste intelligenze
e indipendentemente da tutto
sono convinto, convintissimo
che è giusto prepararsi
all’evento di un loro incontro.
10 alla 25
10 quadri-miliardi di pianeti.
Questa sera vi invito,
prima di dormire,
di contare:
uno,
due,
tre
quattro.
Grazie
(applausi)